nous sommes en 1910 Kees l'homme qui va
révolutionner la théorie économique a
déjà 27 ans il part en Grèce avec son
amant le souci c'est qu'il a le mal de M
il passe donc le voyage aller allongé
dans leur cabine comment est-ce qu'il
tue le temps en lisant la moitié de la
richesse des nations d'Adam Smith ce
gros livre indigeste et la première
pierre de la théorie économique moderne
ce qui fait d'Adam Smith le père de la
théorie économique l'amant de Kees le
voit plonger dans son énorme bouquin il
lui demande ce qu'il en pense c'est un
livre magnifique lui répond
Kees
[Musique]
si vous vous êtes intéressé même
grossièrement à l'économie alors vous
savez probablement qu'il y a deux grands
noms Adam Smith et John Minard Kees et
pour faire simple ces deux penseurs sont
les paires des deux grandes visions de
l'économie la vision libérale classique
et la vision dite kenésienne en
présentant les choses comme ça Smith et
Kees apparaissent comme des rivaux mais
en réalité l'influence de Kees est bien
supérieure c'est lui qui a imaginé la
manière dont la société occidentale du
21e siècle fonctionne parce que c'est
lui qui a imaginé les solutions que les
dirigeants ont choisi pour régler les
problèmes économiques du 20e siècle
c'est aussi lui qui a imaginé la manière
dont la société occidentale du 21e
siècle se comprend parce que c'est lui
qui a fait de l'économie une des
disciplines intellectuelles de référence
sinon la discipline intellectuelle de
référence pour comprendre le monde et
contrairement à Adam Smith Kees n'a pas
mené une vie qui rend difficile de
trouver 10 anecdotes révélatrices même
si j'avais voulu raconter 30 anecdotes
j'aurais dû en jeter un paquet les 10
que j'ai choisi c'est donc la crème de
la crème des deux biographies que j'ai
lu j'ai juste un peu peur que les
dernières anecdotes vous
énervent voici un extrait du journal
intime du père de Kees qui a alors 17
ans sous ma direction mard travaille
régulièrement 3 heur par jour je me fais
l'effet d'un entraîneur comme si je
l'entraînais pour une course ou un Grand
Prix autrement dit le père fait office
de prof parti particulier 3 heur par
jour pourquoi est-ce qu'il s'implique
autant parce que son fils va bientôt
passer des examens qui lui permettront
s'il les réussit de décrocher une bourse
pour intégrer la prestigieuse université
britannique de Cambridge cette anecdote
montre que l'excellence académique et
intellectuelle de Kees est le fruit
d'une intense stimulation parentale le
père de Kees ne s'est pas réveillé
lorsque son fils a eu 17 ans il l'a
stimulé depuis sa plus tendre enfance en
éveillant sa curiosité en lui apprenant
beaucoup de choses et en lui
transmettant le goût de la lecture et
comme les parents n'ont pas les moyens
d'envoyer l'adolescent Kees dans les
plus prestigieuses institutions
académiques anglaises il ment sur les
bourses première étape il faut que ke
décroche une bourse pour Eton Eton c'est
le lycée de l'élite anglaise on retrouve
notamment ses élèves au plus haut
échelons de l'administration britannique
si bien qu'environ un tiers des premiers
ministres anglais sont passés par Eton
les parents de Kees engagent des profs
particuliers pour préparer l'examen
d'entrée ça paye à 14 ans Kees entre à
Eton avec une bourse seconde étape 3 ans
plus tard décrocher une bourse pour
Cambridge cette fois-ci c'est son père
qui est son entraîneur d'après ses
propres mots mais pourquoi est-ce que
son père veut lui-même préparer son fils
pour les examens d'entrée à l'université
de Cambridge parce qu'il est lui-même
prof à Cambridge et prof de quoi vous me
voyez venir prof d'économie et pas
n'importe quel prof d'économie il a
écrit un manuel qui fait autorité mais
un économiste du tournant du 20e siècle
ce n'est pas comme un économiste de 2023
le père de Kees n'est pas un spécialiste
il a une large culture générale et il
est aussi philosophe mathématicien et
logicien je ne dis pas tout cela pour
crier à l'injustice ou nier le mérite de
Kees je rappelle simplement la vérité
dont la pensée occidentale a au 19e
siècle reconnu l'importance cruciale
c'est le milieu qui fait l'homme oui
Kees est un véritable génie mais
économiste trèscultivé formé à Cambridge
il est le fils d'un économiste très
cultivé formé à Cambridge et sa mère
elle est diplômée de
Cambridge nous sommes début 1919 Ludwig
witgenstein un des plus grands
philosophes de la logique du 20e siècle
witgenstein est prisonnier en Italie il
servait dans l'armée austro-hongroise
qui a perdu la guerre et là début 1919
il est retenu dans un camp en Italie il
a avec lui le manuscrit qu'il a écrit
pendant la guerre et il a peur de le
perdre Bertrand Russell un des
philosophes les plus influents du 20e
siècle et l'auteur de l'Histoire de
référence de la philosophie occidentale
Bertrand Russell se soucie du sort de
widgenstein dans la prison italienne
parce qu'ils ont travaillé ensemble à et
qu'il continue d'échanger or Bertrand
Russell est aussi un ami proche de Kees
comme il sait que Kees a un bon réseau
dans l'administration anglaise il lui
demande d'utiliser ses relations pour
aider witgenstein alors kein se fait
pression sur le gouvernement anglais
afin que le manuscrit de witgenstein lui
soit envoyé à lui Kees avec une
expédition sécurisée il le reçoit puis
il l'envoie à Bertrand Russell c'est à
l'influence politique de Kees que nous
devons la publication du tractacus
Logico philosophicus de witgenstein un
déchet de d'œuvre de la philosophie du
20e siècle cette anecdote révèle la
dualité de keines en tant qu'économiste
de haut niveau il fréquente la haute
administration la finance et le monde
des affaires mais il a également un pied
dans l'élite culturelle et cela il le
doit notamment à son appartenance au
groupe de Bloomsbury le nom groupe de
Bloomsbury vient du quartier de
Bloomsbury au centre de Londres où se
tiennent les réunions les membres du
groupe sont des artistes et
intellectuels anticonformistes la
plupart formée à Cambridge parmi eux il
y a Virginia Wolf une des plus célèbre
romancière du 20e siècle à travers le
groupe de Bloomsbury Kees est en contact
avec l'élite culturelle occidentale de
l'époque peintre français philosophes
allemands romanciers russes et cetera et
ce milieu social très spécial lui
inspire sa vision personnelle du bonheur
contrairement à beaucoup d'économistes
Kees ne pense pas que l'homme moderne
sera heureux en consommant plus de biens
et de services ce qu'il imagine lui
c'est que les gens seront heureux
lorsqu'ils auront assez de temps libre à
consacrer à la contemplation et à la
création d'œuvres d'art
les droits d'auteur représentent en
général une petite fraction du prix d'un
livre autour de 10 % même si ça varie
selon les situations si c'est assez
faible c'est parce que c'est l'éditeur
qui prend le risque économique c'est lui
qui finance l'impression du premier
stock d'exemplaire sans savoir s'ils se
vendront mais si c'est l'auteur qui pie
lui-même l'impression alors il peut
tirer un revenu bien plus conséquent des
ventes de son livre c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui des auteurs gagnent très
bien leur vie en s'autoéditant sur
Amazon ils gagnent trois quatre voir CIN
fois plus qu'avec un éditeur
traditionnel l'impression à la demande
n'existe pas à l'époque de Kees mais il
a les moyens de payer de sa poche
l'impression d'un premier stock c'est le
choix qu'il fait en 1919 comme des
tracas administratifs ralentissent la
publication de son livre Kees décide de
prendre les choses en main en finançant
l'impression il devient le maître du
projet son éditeur la prestigieuse
maison d'édition mcmelan est réduite à
un rôle de distributeur le rapport de
force est inversé c'est ke qui décide et
c'est l'éditeur qui devra se contenté de
10 % du prix du livre il ne regrettera
pas sa décision son livre Les
Conséquences économiques de la paix est
le plus célèbre panflet économique de
l'histoire il se vend comme des petits
pains et donc Kane se gagne beaucoup
d'argent mais il peste parce qu'il ne
touche que 15 % des ventes à l'étranger
or c'est aux États-Unis que les ventes
explosent pourquoi est-ce que le livre
marche si bien parce qu'il crée le
scandale les belligérants de la Première
Guerre mondiale viennent de signer le
traité de versaill donc les vainqueurs
vendent entre guillemets le traiter à
l'opinion les populations ont tellement
souffert pendant la guerre maintenant il
faut qu'elle pense que ça se termine
bien le président américain Wilson
architecte majeur du traité avec ses 14
points reçoit le prix Nobel de la paix
juste après mais le panflet de Kees sort
2 jours plus tard il démontre clairement
chiffres à l'appui que le traité de
Versailles va appauvrir les peuple de
l'Europe prophète il suggère que les
réparations écrasantes imposées à
l'Allemagne vont engendrer des troubles
politiques et de nouvelles tensions en
Europe et si le diagnostic de Kees est
très convaincant c'est parce qu'il a
lui-même participé aux négociations qui
on abouti au traité de Versailles c'est
d'ailleurs cette position qui lui a
permis de sauver le manuscrit de
witgenstein il critique donc le traité
de Versailles avec la légitimité d'un
acteur de premier plan en plus de
montrer que le traité est une mauvaise
solution il se moque des dirigeants
politiques il compare par exemple le
président américain Wilson à Don kishot
c'est-à-dire un idéaliste fou et il dit
que George Clémenceau le représentant de
la France est un vieillard qui voit le
monde avec de vieilles
lunett au début de la Première Guerre
mondiale les investissements financiers
de Kees valent environ 5000 livres
sterling l'équivalent de 500000 dollars
d'aujourd'hui à la fin de la guerre il
valent 15000 livres FO 3 en 4 ans super
c'est tellement rapide que c'est suspect
parce que Kees ne se contente pas de
lire le Financial Times pendant la
guerre non il travaille au niveau le
plus élevé de l'administration
économique britannique il joue un rôle
clé dans les questions financières liées
à la guerre autrement dit il a accès aux
secrets économiques du gouvernement en
même temps qu'il spécule sur des valeurs
liées aux décisions du gouvernement
c'est pas un conflit d'intérêt ça à
l'époque ça passait mais aujourd'hui ça
créerait un énorme scandale apparemment
Kees n'a jamais fait des recommandations
pour favoriser ses propres
investissement mais il a bien évidemment
utilisé les secrets auxquels il avait
accès pour faire fructifier son capital
ce qui viole le principe fondamental
d'égale accès à l'information autrement
dit Keyes commet au cours de la première
guerre mondiale ce qu'on appelle des
délis d'initiés cette anecdote montre
qu'il était un spéculateur il commence à
spéculer en bourse au début de la
vingtaine sa compréhension des
mécanismes économiques lui permet de
monter en 5 ans à plus de 500 livres
sterling l'équivalent de 50000 dollars
d'aujourd'hui il continue et au début de
la Première Guerre mondiale il a
multiplié son capital par neu la série
de succès continue après la guerre il
obtient des gains rapides en spéculant
sur les monnaaies donc kein c'est
vraiment un investisseur doué sa
réputation d'investisseur grandit au
point que les gens lui demandent
d'investir leur argent la famille les
amis et même l'Université de Cambridge
ke se crée alors un fond
d'investissement au début de 1920 il
mise sur un renchérissement du dollar
par rapport au mon européennes et pas de
chance c'est l'inverse qui se produit
Kees perd plus de 22000 livres sterling
l'équivalent de millions de dollars
d'aujourd'hui et oui même les hommes les
plus intelligents ne peuvent pas prévoir
l'avenir avec certitude mais Kees a les
moyens de réduire l'incertitude des
marchés il interroge ses contact
politique pour prévoir la tendance des
devises il obtient un prêt de 5000
livres et en moins de 2 ans son fond et
lui-même sont revenus dans le verre 2
ans plus tard en 1924 il est lui-même
multimillionnaire en dollars
d'aujourd'hui sa fortune personnelle
c'est à entre 5 et 10 millions de
dollars donc Kin est devenu très riche
par la spéculation si vous connaissez un
peu sa théorie économique ça doit vous
étonner en effet il dit que la
spéculation est un facteur majeur
d'instabilité pour l'économie il compare
même le fonctionnement des marchés
boursiers à un
casino si vous voulez voyager en Russie
aujourd'hui c'est compliqué mais c'est
possible le plus chiant c'est que vous
ne pourrez pas utiliser vos cartes
bancaire donc il faudra vous trimballer
avec des liases de billets moi c'est ça
qui me retient d'aller faire un tour à
Saint-Pétersbourg alors que c'est
l'histoire de quelques heures en voiture
maintenant imaginez voyager en Russie en
1925 7 ans après la Révolution non
seulement vous ne pouvez pas commander
un visa sur internet mais surtout les
problèmes pratiques sont bien plus
lourds que l'invalidité des cartes
bancaires et pourtant keines se rend à
Moscou il a été invité à une conférence
pourquoi donc prend-il ce risque parce
qu'il vient de se marier avec une femme
russe à 42 ans il épouse la célèbre
ballerine Lydia lopokova qui a elle 33
ans ils vont célébrer leur mariage avec
la famille russe à Saint-Pétersbourg qui
s'appelle à l'époque Leningrad
c'est-à-dire ville de Lénine que kein se
marie est étonnant parce qu'il a
toujours été homosexuel c'est d'autant
plus étonnant qu'il a toujours mené sa
vie romantique avec une grande liberté
surtout pour l'époque mais un soir
d'hiver 1921 il voit liydia lopokova
danser dans une adaptation de La Belle
au bois Dormand de Tchaikovski et il
tombe amoureux en plus d'être belle la
ballerine est célèbre sa troupe vend
même des poupées Lydia aux foules qui
remplissent les salles Kane se réserve
les places les plus proches de la scène
qui sont les plus chers il va la voir en
coulisse et l'invite à déjeuner ils sont
mutuellement envoûtés elle par
l'exceptionnel l'intelligence de Kees
lui par l'énergie et le talent de Lydia
quelques années plus tard il forment un
couple célèbre Lydia qui a été élevé
dans le respect des intellectuels admire
la célébrité et l'autorité de Kees mais
tout n'est pas rose au début Kees a
toujours des aventures homosexuelles et
il faut que Lydia le supplie pour qu'il
accepte de lui être fidèle autre souci
les amis de Bloomsbury sont réticents à
intégrer Lydia qui n'a pas exactement
leur mentalité ni leur aisence
intellectuelle elle devra attendre
longtemps avant d'être pleinement
acceptée dans le groupe enfin pour des
raisons non élucidées le couple n'a pas
eu d'enfants pardon pour l'interruption
mais j'ai une question à vous poser vous
croyez vraiment que les gens ont lu tous
les livres dont il parle bien sûr que
non sinon on ne pourrait pas parler de
grand-chose et oui il y a 24 heures dans
une journée et il faut travailler manger
dormir et sortir le
chien donc le secret de la culture
générale ce n'est pas de lire des livres
c'est quoi alors en fait il n'y a pas un
seul secret il y en a C les étudiants et
les personnes les plus cultivées les
profs et les intellectuels connaissent
ces cinq secrets vous savez vous avez lu
Renant comme moi mais ils se gardent
bien d'en parler les gens qui les
découvrent réussissent à développer
rapidement et facilement leur culture
générale parce que leur rapport au
savoir a changé et une fois qu'ils
appliquent les cinq secrets ils
comprennent toutes les références des
personnes cultivées ils savent
s'exprimer avec profondeur sur n'importe
quel sujet ils brillent par leur culture
dans les conversations et dans les
débats et ils ont le recul nécessaire
pour faire preuve d'esprit critique ça
vous intéresse et bien je vous révèle
les cinq secrets et je vous explique
comment les appliquer dès aujourd'hui
pour vous cultiver 10 fois plus
rapidement sans vous prendre la tête
pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit sur celui qui est dans la
description de la vidéo c'est l'histoire
de 10 secondes donc faites-le maintenant
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier
secret qui vous attendra bien au chaud
dans votre boîte mail après avoir
regardé cette vidéo voilà voilà je vous
ai dit ce que je voulais vous vous dire
bonne
vidéo nous sommes au début de 1932 Kees
qui est prof à Cambridge se rend chez
son assistant Richard Cann dans son
excitation intellectuelle il entre sans
prévenir comme il a l'habitude de faire
et là il tombe sur une scène
embarrassante son assistant Richard KH
est allongé sur le sol sur des coussins
avec Johan Robinson elle aussi
assistante de Kees le souci c'est que
Johan Robinson est marié à Austin
Robinson lui aussi assistant de Kees je
résume une assistante de Kees trompe un
assistant de Kees avec un assistant de
Kees Kees décide de ne rien faire mais
il est bien embêté par cette affaire
pourtant il est loin d'être un puritain
alors pourquoi est-ce que cette affaire
lui prend la tête parce qu'elle trouble
le travail de ses assistants qui est
vraiment précieux pour lui en fait le
terme d'assistant est un euphémisme qui
minimise leur rôle réel cette anecdote
révèle que ke est en réalité le chef
d'une équipe intellectuelle ce qu'on
appelle le cercle de Cambridge Cambridge
Circus en anglais de la même manière que
nous croyons spontanément qu'un chef
politique prend ses décisions seul et
qu'il impose sa volonté au pays entier
nous croyons que les grands penseurs
travaillent seul et que leurs idées
s'imposent d'elle-même dans l'opinion
mais c'est souvent une illusion en tout
cas ça allait évidemment avec Kees s'il
réussit à révolutionner l'économie et à
marquer la pensée occidentale avec son
chef-dœuvre la théorie générale de
l'emploi de l'intérêt et de la monnaie
c'est grâce aux brillants esprits qui
l'ont aidé dans l'ombre non seulement il
a pu leur soumettre ses idées et leur
faire corriger mais ses assistants lui
ont également fourni des idées cruciales
Johan Robinson par exemple montre que le
laisser faire est une illusion
l'économie réelle ne correspond pas du
tout à ce que décrivent les manuels
classiques en réalité la prospérité est
un résultat politique l'influence
intellectuelle de cette géniale femme
économiste est telle que certains
historiens de l'économie estiment que la
thèse de base de la théorie générale de
keines était en réalité déjà présente
dans des articles de Johan Robinson
publiés avant et l'autre assistant avec
lequel elle trompe son mari Richard Cann
n'est nul autre que l'auteur du concept
crucial du multiplicateur grâce auquel
ke justifie l'intervention de l'État
dans l'économie lorsque l'État dépense 1
€ il enclenche un cercle vertueux de
création de valeur ce qui transforme
l'euro initial en 1,5 2 voire 3 4
€. nous sommes au cours de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale l'Allemagne mène des
campagnes de bombardement contre le
Royaume-Uni à Cambridge Kee s'est
parfois affecté à une mission de
surveillance des incendie au sommet de
la chapelle gothique médiévale armée de
PEL son coéquipier et lui doivent
pousser toute bombe incendiaire
allemande égarée sur le toit au cas où
l'une d'ellees n'exploserait pas lors
d'un raid aérien et un jour son
coéquipier est Friedrich AEK oui ayek
l'ennemi idéologique de Keyes ayek le
défenseur du marché l'économiste qui
voit ce que recommande Kees
l'intervention de l'État comme un danger
qu'est-ce que Hayek fait à Cambridge et
bien la London School of Economics où
enseigne ayek a été délocalisée à
Cambridge pour des raisons de sécurité
les deux grands économistes se croisent
donc au quotidien pendant plusieurs
années et leur guerre idéologique ne les
empêche pas d'avoir des rapports
cordiauxx cependant le conflit était
plus intense au tournant des années 1930
les idées de Kees commencent à se
diffuser grâce à ses premi livres et aux
articles de ses partisans ayek qui
comprend que ses idées remettent en
cause les principes fondamentaux du
libéralisme ayek est leur plus féroce
adversaire mais le conflit n'est pas
simplement intellectuel il faut
convertir les étudiants en économie qui
hésitent entre les deux grandes
orientations idéologiques et à ce jeu
les kenésiens sont les meilleurs en
particulier Johan Robinson la géniale
assistante de Kees Johan Robinson réussi
à faire migrer des étudiants de la
London School of Economics à Cambridge
où ils pourront se former avec les
kénésiens la différence entre Kees et
Hayek c'est que Kees est très
charismatique il est presque un chef de
secte lorsqu'ils sont tous les deux à
Cambridge pendant la guerre Kees ne se
sent pas menacé par ayek il pense avoir
gagné la guerre des idées mais ayek
reprend du poil de la bête en 1944 grâce
au succès de son chef-dœuvre la route de
la
servitude nous sommes en janvier 1923
Kees assemble un consortium
d'investisseurs et et rachète la
majorité des parts du journal
britannique The Nation and affenam à ne
pas confondre avec le magazine américain
The Nation Kees se nomme lui-même
président du conseil d'administration du
journal puis pousse le rédacteur en chef
du journal à partir pourquoi devenir
propriétaire d'un magazine cela fait
plusieurs années que kein écrit pour le
Manchester Guardian et il se rend compte
de l'influence que lui donnent ses
articles il est lu dans le monde de la
finance des affaires de l'administration
et de la politique bref les décideurs
sont sensibles à ces idées il se dit
qu'en étant le chef d'un journal il
pourra décupler son audience cette
anecdote montre que keenes a été un
intellectuel avant d'être un théoricien
tout du moins il a été reconnu comme
intellectuel avant de l'être comme
théoricien dans les années 1920 sa
stratégie consiste à faire gagner ses
idées dans l'élite économique et
politique un journal c'est le bon
instrument pour cela et comme il est un
ami en or Kane se sert aussi de The
Nation pour soutenir tout le groupe de
Bloomsbury il offre à ses amis une
plateforme pour leurs idées et contribu
par là à leur futur renommé et fortune
en moins d'un an Kees est l'intellectuel
le plus influents de la gauche
britannique tous les hommes politiques
veulent son soutien lors des élections
seulement la stratégie de keines échoue
à convertir les dirigeants ils
connaissent ses idées mais ils font
confiance aux experts aux conseillers
économiques qui s'expriment avec du
jargon et des formules mathématiques
tandis que keines est un intellectuel
qui parle au grand public presque un
vulgarisateur il change donc de
stratégie dans les années 1930 pour
convertir les dirigeants il faut
convertir leurs conseillers il faut que
les conseillers économiques deviennent
kénésiens quand j'étais étudiant j'ai
longtemps buggé sur le même problème en
histoire on nous apprend en simplifiant
que le président Roosevelt sort les
États-Unis de la crise de 29 grâce au
New Deal et on nous dit que c'est une
politique de relance de l'économie
inspirée par la théorie de Kees or le
New Deal la mise en pratique commence en
1933 tandis que la théorie générale de
Kees la théorie est publiée en 1936
comment t'expliquer que la théorie soit
appliquée avant d'être publiée et bien
en fait Kees n'a pas attendu 1936 pour
proposer sa solu solution à la crise de
29 l'année même de la crise il écrit un
essai intitulé est-ce que Lloyd George
peut le faire dans lequel il examine les
propositions du candidat Lyd George pour
réduire le chômage il y défend un
ambitieux programme de travaux publics
et c'est ce programme qui inspirera le
New Deal du président rosevelt en fait
les États-Unis sont le laboratoire des
idées de Kees ça commence avec ce qu'on
appelle le brain trust le groupe de
conseillers de Roosevelt qui ont joué un
rôle crucial dans la formulation du New
Deal puis les idées de Kees pénètrent le
monde académique américain tout
particulièrement à Harvard cela en
retour les renforce dans
l'administration américaine leur
influence perdure jusqu'aux années 1970
les dernières figures emblématiques du
kenésianisme aux États-Unis sont le
président John Fitzgerald Kennedy et son
conseiller économique John Kenneth
Galbreth galbress qui est un peu le Kees
américain à la différence qu'il n'a pas
écrit de chefdœuvre théorique en
économie galbress a été le prof
d'économie de Kennedy à Harvard donc
quand Kennedy veut s'entourer de
brillants intellectuels pour compenser
son image de jeune beau gosse
inexpérimenté il pense à son professeur
à la fin des années 1960 le kenésianisme
a gagné aux États-Unis c'est l'idéologie
économique des profes d'université comme
des
technocrates lorsqu'une discipline
intellectuelle devient une discipline
académique les profs et les élèves ont
besoin d'un livre qui fournisse une vue
d'ensemble en synthétisant tout le
savoir de la discipline c'est ça un
manuel et bien souvent un seul manuel
s'impose comme la référence pour
l'auteur c'est le jackpot des
générations d'étudiants ou même de cur
ux qui veulent découvrir la discipline
bref des masses de lecteurs achètent le
manuel année après année en général
pendant des décennies ça représente une
grosse rente jusqu'à ce qu'un changement
de paradigme pour parler comme Thomas
Kun intervienne dans la discipline on a
alors besoin d'un nouveau manuel en 1947
Lori tarchis un économiste canadien
formé au canadiianisme à Cambridge en
1947 Lori tarchi a bien l'impression que
son manuel elements of Economics est en
train de devenir le manuel d'économie
kénésien de référence les les ventes ont
décollé seulement ça ne plaît pas à tout
le monde des mouvements anticommunistes
accusent le manuel d'être un cheval de
tro pour les idées marxistes ils mettent
la pression sur les universités au bout
d'un certain temps l'autocensure du
monde académique tue le manuel un autre
économiste saisit alors l'opportunité
d'écrire le manuel d'économie de
référence les idées kénésiennes sont si
influentes qu'il est impossible de les
ignorer mais en leur donnant le monopole
on devient la cible de groupe de
pression le défi consiste donc à
enseigner ensemble les idées kénésiennes
et les idées classiques Paul Samuelson
réussit son coup en réalisant une
synthèse son manuel l'économique sorti
en 1948 se vend à des millions
d'exemplaires et du coup Samuelson
devient millionnaire grâce au manuel
d'économie le plus vendu de tous les
temps mais ce que révèle cette anecdote
c'est qu'au cours des 30 glorieuses les
idées de keines ne sont pas accueillies
à bras ouverts aux États-Unis non elles
sont combattues et même diabolisées les
kénésiens sont d'abord la cible de la
propagande conservatrice puis ils sont
même les victimes du maccartisme cette
chasse aux sorcières qui prend le nom du
sénateur américain responsable d'une
hystérie antiommuniste de plusieurs
années certains kénésiens font donc les
frais d'une paranoïa libérale et
conservatrice mais d'un autre côté ce
n'est pas à 100 % un délire paranoïque
les idées de kein sont radicales donc
elles attirent des socialistes depuis le
début dans les fait beaucoup de
kénésiens américains sont en effet des
sympathisants communistes au cours des
TR glorieuses et comme on peut s'y
attendre dans le Lot quelques-uns ne se
contentent pas d'une adhésion
intellectuelle ils vont jusqu'à agir
clandestinement pour
l'URSS
si vous aimez l'esprit de cette vidéo à
savoir découvrir des choses
intéressantes en allant à l'essentiel et
sans se prendre la tête alors vous
aimerez probablement mon programme
Culture Express c'est un programme
méthodique pour devenir facilement une
personne cultivée en seulement quelques
mois il couvre tous les domaines de la
culture générale vous maîtriserez les
connaissances essentielles sur
l'histoire de l'humanité sur l'histoire
de France en économie en scienceces
politique en psychologie en Scien en
littérature en art en religion et en
philosophie vous ne saurez plus jamais à
à cours de choses à dire et vous
gagnerez la confiance nécessaire pour
briller en toutes circonstances vous
pouvez en savoir plus en cliquant sur le
lien qui s'affiche en haut à droite ou
bien sur celui qui est dans la
description ou bien encore en tapant
directement l'adresse qui s'affiche à
l'écran dans la barre de recherche mais
je pense que la meilleure façon de vous
donner une idée du programme et
d'écouter ce que les membres ont à en
dire Valentine qui reconnaît l'énorme
quantité de travail que ce programme a
représenté pour moi dit je cite que
c'est une véritable mine d'or
l'essentiel est là tout est simple
pratique très bien expliqué concentré il
n'y a plus qu'à copier et à apprendre ce
travail est vraiment formidable et
passionnant Maxence m'écrit directement
dans les commentaires en dessous d'une
vidéo du programme la formation est
vraiment remarquable j'étais un peu
dubitatif étant donné le prix initial
mais je ne regrette pas c'est un vrai
travail de synthèse que tu nous proposes
et le format vidéo est très adapté pour
moi qui est une mémoire essentiellement
auditive le choix des thèmes et des
chapitres est pertinent et je trouve que
tu as trouvé la dose d'approfondissement
parfaite à la fois précis mais sans
fiuriture vincent lui fait carrément ma
pub j'ai d'ailleurs recommandé votre
formation à ma sœur qui travaille comme
diplommate la semaine dernière elle a
déjà eu l'occasion de mettre à profit
dans ses discussions les connaissances
que vous avez diffusé vous verrez
d'autres témoignages comme ceci dans les
commentaires si vous rejoignnez le
programme et si vous vous inscrivez vous
bénéficiez d'une garantie résultat une
fois que vous aurez terminé le programme
je vous rembourserai intégralement si
vous estimer que vous n'avez pas acquis
une solide culture générale si vous
voulez en savoir plus cliquez sur le
lien qui s'affiche en haut à droite ou
bien sur celui qui est dans la
description ou bien encore taper
directement l'adresse qui s'affiche à
l'écran dans la barre de recherche plus
de 800 membres ont déjà tiré par de ce
programme et je seraai ravi qu'il en
soit de même pour vous dans tous les cas
j'espère que la vidéo vous a plu je suis
romain et vous vous étiez sur 1idé de
culture générale rappelez-vous vous
n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête pour vous intéresser au meilleur de
la
[Musique]
pensée